la suite maintenant et la fin de notre
série de reportages sur la vie sexuelle
en france en 2010 autour d'une question
en quoi at elle évolué ces dernières
années
ce soir la banalisation des images
aujourd'hui les films x les films
pornographiques par exemple sont
largement diffusés et consommer sur
internet les tabous sont tombés la
sexualité en est elle vraiment modifié
enquête julien duperey vivien roussel ce
magasin il y entre comme s'il allait au
supermarché
sauf qu'en pleine zone commerciale de
nantes il s'agit bien d'un sex shop et
nouvelles choses
un lieu ouvert et sans tabou à l'image
de ce couple de trentenaires ingénieur
informatique
ils sont ensemble depuis 10 ans et leur
amour va de pair avec une sexualité
assumée
y compris quand il s'agit de parler des
films pornographiques
ge qui le regardent tous les deux moi
j'aime bien temps en temps pourquoi pas
pas systématique mais c'est un jeu comme
un mouton est exactement mais voilà
c'est un jeu comme un autre c'est un
stimulant 1st stimulante
ça ouvre un petit peu là fétide de voir
le jour de regarder un film x
une démarche de couple synonyme pour de
complicité et d'intimité menthe à l'eau
ce leader ça permet de mieux se
connaître la joie d'en parler tous les
jours cela permettra voire tabou
justement donc dans un couple eur et
pouvoir flasher ses affaires un service
payant c'est pas le sujet du samedi soir
à table entre amis de dire aujourd'hui
on allait là je vous montre ce qu'on a
acheté la démarche est pur plaisir
évidemment mais on va pas me sens vont t
ils ont réjouira tout le monde se
regarde dans un récent sondage près de
48% des personnes interrogées affirment
regarder un film pornographique au moins
deux fois par an et ces personnes ne les
dizaines pas forcément seul puisque près
d'un tiers le sait même en coupe
sedan dans les ardennes en plein centre
ville il se passe dans cette ancienne
sous préfecture des choses pas très
administrative dans tes pensées dutronc
se transforme en font peur et lorsqu'un
violent le un réalisateur deux actrices
nous sommes sur le tournage d'une scène
pornographique au menu petits scénarios
lingerie fine du sexe grand public
pourra tirer sans effrayer
comme c'est quelque chose qui est très
posé sur le
situation le scénario plus la tension
érotique que sur vraiment le l'apparence
porno c'est plus ce sont des plus de ce
nouveau couple ou warfare 2 heures de
tournage et la vidéo sera disponible
directement sur le site internet de la
société de production car il est loin le
temps où le x et son parfum d'interdît
aller sa place dans les salles de cinéma
conséquence de mai 68 le sexe envahi les
écrans finale au mal ça me plaît à les
regarder mais pour rire
la veille de noël on va avec des
nouveaux pères angoua 35 ans plus tard
et avec la révolution internet la
consommation de pornographie a quitté la
rue pour la maison dorénavant le sexe se
consomme à l'abri des regards dans la
sphère intime ce que vivent les français
tous les jours c'est de moins en moins
de tabous sur leur sexualité et sur le
plaisir les femmes revendiquent le droit
au plaisir et non pas honte et ne se
cache plus dans leur recherche de
plaisirs tout autant que les hommes
par contre effectivement dans la sphère
publique le sexe est beaucoup plus caché
qu'il l'était il ya une vingtaine
d'années en alors au début des années
2000 pour reconquérir cet espace public
le monde de la pornographie a trouvé une
astuce lancé la mode des jouets sexuels
l'industrie du divertissement prospère
grâce à ses produits dérivés et la règle
vaut aussi pour la pornographie
l'année dernière trois millions de
sex-toys auraient été achetés ses + 12 %
sur un an
à tel point que maintenant le sexe à son
salon ici à lyon 10 mille mètres carrés
interdit aux moins de 16 ans entre
vibromasseur tenues affriolantes et
spectacles des stars du x
tout est fait pour banaliser l'aspect
crû de l'industrie du sexe et ça marche
on attire les familles qui est
intéressant c'est de voir les parents
avec les enfants qui ont forcément plus
de 16 18 ans qui viennent sur nos salons
15000 visiteurs sur deux jours
et le succès est le même dans toute la
france aujourd'hui si l'industrie de la
pornographie n'a pas réussi à se
débarrasser de son image sulfureuse elle
est tout de même parvenu à faire de
certains amoureux des consommateurs
assidus